they can litters menace pedestrians and
endanger their riders lives over the
past year app enabled electric scooters
have popped up in cities around the
world inviting a weary public to hop
arrived as indignant local governments
scramble to regulate them it may come as
a surprise then that East Cooter's could
be exactly what traffic choked cities
need this is your bloomberg quick take
on e schooners download an app find a
scooter unlock it and go for a ride when
you're done leave it behind rides can
cost less than two dollars
there's birdlime scoots skip both uber
and lyft have scooters now as well
they're new and they sort of by their
essence they're all over the place so if
you're not using them they get in your
way and because people are just learning
how to use them they tend to ride them
in obnoxious ways in a lot of places
he's become sort of a symbol of the
technology industry which annoys people
at launch cities like Cleveland bans
them while San Francisco halted
operations for several months to create
a permit system that capped the number
of scooters allowed still growth has
continued Byrd and lime each offer
scooters in more than 40 cities but
despite the controversies a scooters
have their defenders in dense urban
areas cars often aren't the fastest way
to get around many cities have turned to
bike-share systems and dedicated bike
lanes because they take up less space
than cars and save on carbon emissions
some urban planners also see a scooters
as part of the future of city
transportation I think the hope would be
that you would eliminate a lot of
shorter car trips that would get a lot
of cars off the road create more
protected lanes and so on and then that
would in turn broaden the demand for
scooters so it would be sort of a
virtuous cycle
but despite burden lime each being
valued at more than 1 billion dollars
it's too early to tell if they will
become viable businesses the things you
look at is how long it takes to pay off
a vehicle and how long a vehicle stays
on the road and we don't know exactly
how much this is but
you know it does seem like you can pay
these things off fairly quickly they're
relatively inexpensive but they also
just get completely trashed very quickly
you're gonna take care of your own bike
you're gonna take care of your own car
but like as they say like no one ever
washes a rental car
you
you